right thanks for coming my name is dawn
I'm the designer of the f-sharp
programming language I work at Microsoft
Research but right now I'm very very
happy doing a two-year gig with the
xamarin team the Microsoft mobile tools
team working with miguel de casa and the
whole gang who make the xamarin tools
for the Android and iOS platforms which
are fantastic tools for doing dotnet
programming targeting Android and iOS
and also covering a range of other
device kind of oriented work for for.net
programmers and I'm yeah so so today
it's it's I'm working on this cutter new
new talk I discovered this is a talk I
initially gave an F sharp exchange and I
I discovered that people actually really
like it like it when the language
designer talks about code they like in
code that they don't like in the
language okay that's it you know we can
all talk about the features in a
programming language and maybe the
history of it and a background of it I
kind of cover some of that but we also
want to know how to use the features
well and just because I've got an
opinion on that doesn't mean I'm right
about that but I guess people like to at
least hear my opinion and then they tell
me their opinions back pretty strongly
about about the right way to use f sharp
or the or the wrong way to use it so one
way of approaching that instead of just
saying hey let's have an argument about
coding styles or something is just say
look I look at this code and I really
love it this is what is this forms part
of the reason about why F sharp exists
is to support some of this some of the
different kinds of coding that I'll be
yeah be talking about I will be talking
about object-oriented programming a
little bit and how object programming
kind of plays out in F sharp and where
we kind of find a place to stop on the
slippery slope of object-oriented
programming there are places you can
stop on the way down without going all
the way all the way down right
so let let's begin as I said in its
opinion I've covered some of this now
some of you might not know much about F
sharp I understand that I the last time
I gave this talk was to an F sharp
oriented audience I try to read you get
a little bit probably haven't done that
completely so if you have some
familiarity with sharps if you have some
familiarity with the language like elm
or with maybe you've done some
functional programming somewhere in your
background then that that that will help
a little bit but it's a pretty
lightweight talk so you shouldn't you
should be able to follow along so what
do Microsoft say F sharp is f sharp is
partly sponsored by Mark soft-bodied
this is this is what is on the marks of
the cognate site for dotnet programming
F sharp is the open source
cross-platform functional language for
dotnet and that's why it's there to fill
that niche in the.net platform to
support functional programming extremely
well in the context of F net and that's
why we started F sharp as why it exists
today is because that's an important
that economically commercially
technically valuable thing to be
providing in the context of the.net
ecosystem and it's valuable because it's
a super productive and super accurate
way of programming and that can be used
for all sorts of different things but
it's because we want to bring functional
program internet and to bring dotnet to
functional programming I probably said
that in like 2005 2006 when we started F
sharp those are probably the exact words
I used and that's still why F sharp
exists today and it's a mission it needs
to to serve that said f sharp is
actually more than dotnet these days
I'll be covering that F sharp has a
fantastic JavaScript compiler as it's
actually two great JavaScript compiler
it's one of you talking today is called
fable and it's particularly good because
it really brings F sharp into the Java
into the JavaScript ecosystem it's
packaged as a node NPM package and so
you know if you're in the JavaScript
ecosystem you'll find it very natural to
use F sharp as a as the wide
javascript code and the similar way to
how typescript is done as well okay so
this a little bit about where F sharp is
today so def shop is open source open
source cross-platform it is a certain
sense in which it's as a language and as
a community of positions itself to be
neutral the word neutral can mean many
different things you have many different
contributors to a language there's sort
of a demilitarized zone as there's a
group called the f-sharp Software
Foundation which is a nonprofit
organization in the United States it
kind of is a similar thing to the Python
Software Foundation it's set up
particularly for sort of community and
educational purposes and it allows all
the different people who contribute to
f-sharp
Microsoft is one major contributor they
sponsor my time and they sponsor several
other people to work on it but we have
contributors from JetBrains we have
contributors from companies who use F
sharp relatively speaking F sharp is a
relatively sort of contributing
community there are lots of the
companies using it also contribute to
the actual tooling and the and the the
whole stack from language design all the
way through to tooling and libraries and
it's in the we we think of it as
independent in yeah in that kind of
neutral sense it there contributors but
that the there's an independent zone
where everyone comes together and that's
primarily through the f-sharp Software
Foundation and their activities so right
across the stack we accept contributions
right through all the tooling that
includes a visual of sharp tools if a
visual studio includes Visual Studio
code plug-ins for F sharp it includes
the JetBrains Rider tooling for F sharp
so right across the stack it's a very
self empowered community there's a the F
sharp community through their shop
Software Foundation very much owned this
own the message about F sharp about what
you know it we wouldn't if you go to
look for testimonials about f-sharp you
wouldn't go and look for microsoft case
studies or something like that you go to
the f-sharp Software Foundation they own
the story and they're very good at
telling that story you know in a in a
powerful way so air shaft org is the
place they're on the professional
tooling side the xamarin the group I
work with now Microsoft mobile tools
provider shop tools for Android and iOS
and I use those every day and they're
they're great and getting even better
the visual life sharp tools are
Microsoft sort of professional tools
they are part of Visual Studio all the
different profiles of Visual Studio and
for the cross-platform story through the
Linux and OS X we of course have mono
but we have the Debian and RPM packages
and it's incredibly good cross-platform
story through net core underneath this
tooling there's a single component
called the f-sharp compiler service
which is really the implementation of
their sharp available as a library it's
got this type checker it's got its
parser it's got a selector it's got the
colorizer it's got all the different
pieces that you need to analyze their
sharp code it's got their dynamic the
dynamic execution engine it's got the
the code the cogent engine there's this
actually crossed compiles to JavaScript
so it has a version of the F sharp
compiler service component which is
entirely JavaScript used to generate
JavaScript in the browser the F sharp
compiling itself in the in the browser
and so that's a component that underlies
everything I said there's fable for F
sharp to JavaScript and something I
won't be talking about today but it's
incredibly exciting development for F
sharp is this kind of opinionated
full-stack putting some of these pieces
together thing called safe if you just
Google for that and that basically takes
a saw a web story which is called suave
or Saturn built on asp.net core takes
Azure takes F affable for F sharp the
JavaScript and what's the e form
is why Mabel and elvish is the is the
way of I will be talking about that the
way of programming the web dynamic web
view using an elm like programming model
it's a really great stack for end-to-end
programming with F sharp from client
right through the server and on the
language design side we've just finished
up on f-sharp 4.1 I'm beginning to put
together what's in a shop but probably
for various technical reasons jump
straight there f-sharp 4.5 because we
used up some version numbers in between
in some silly releases of various
components that we go to align
everything and just go straight to
f-sharp 4.5 we have a language design
process you can get involved in you can
look here under the f-sharp software
foundation's github for our organization
at the design usually start with
suggestions you can vote on them to
comment on them put whatever you like
there the design is where the rfcs go
and then they get translated into pull
requests to the actual implementation
that's what we did an f-sharp 4.0 I
won't go through that just sort of list
of things we did F sharp 4.1 we did
these we focused a lot on allowing
people to use these unboxed struct
representations of a range of different
data types in a very simple way just by
adding an attribute to things right okay
so that sorry that's the vs code plug in
a very community-driven great bit of
tooling for f-sharp get Visual Studio
code open an F sharp far little turn
it'll prompt you to install these tools
called iron IDE and give you your
editing whether you're on Linux or Mac
or
or whatever this is the dotnet course
story f-sharp is in the the.net sdk
which is the sdk for dotnet core
programming it's a default part of that
sdk so wherever you see f-sharp every
wherever you see neck core C sharp and
dotnet core being supported f-sharp is
also going to be supported there for
example you can do dotnet core
programming to do AWS lambda functions
and they of course did the c-sharp
samples first just yesterday because
they running those who thought net core
just yesterday they put out the F AWS
Amazon put out the templates for doing F
sharp AWS lambda function functions
right this how you get started on it new
- Lang a sharp and build a separate of
the usual thing we've got my core and I
can find out more here right and that's
the fable JavaScript compiler I
mentioned uses babel underneath produced
food is good javascript code and has
yeah you I've just been up and follow
through if you into the into the
front-end programming and just to say
just on the summer about f-sharp the
methodologically it feels very different
to c-sharp okay it's like and the way we
capture that in a pair of words is to
say that F sharp people adopt functional
first programming and that that will
play out what that means in some
examples but it does feel different and
I've encourage you to get into the mode
of what it means to be an f-sharp
programmer don't just approach it as
like oh another syntax or C sharp or
something it's not like that
methodologically it feels and is
different to c-sharp programming so some
affinities as of course you know there's
lots of relationship but the functional
first approach is a is a great one this
is one analysis done for the cyclists
aim project it was application to
evaluate the revenue drew from balancing
service Kahn
in the UK in energy industry had done an
analysis done by Simon cousins that was
there were differences here beyond the
language this was an offshore team this
is a type team of two or three f-sharp
programmers working in the UK but you
could see there's a scales of difference
here and the c-sharp project took about
five years had about eight developers
and didn't implement all the contracts
the f-sharp project took place of one
year peaked at three devs I mean one had
prior experience with f-sharp and all
the contracts were fully implemented on
the what were those lines of code you
can see here we had 56 thousand lines of
braces in the c-sharp code we had loved
blank lines we had three thousand null
checks we had we had lots of comments
but you know maybe I don't own anyway
okay yeah maybe this could have been a
bit higher I like comments all right
then you see the test code the plenty of
tests in the F sharp code out of the
total here one third of it was tests
actually saw a higher proportion of
tests in the F sharp code C shop here
just to say one particularly telling
statistics is this one this is 2,000
try-catch statements in the c-sharp code
so there clearly exceptions had got
completely out of hand in this it's an
AC with an asynchronous application I
don't think they were using the async
features of c-sharp properly and are
probably disrupting try-catch handlers
around every single callback and they're
not having anywhere to send the
exception when they caught it and just
kind of logging it or something like
that thing ended like nine in the in the
F sharp code and that doesn't surprise
me too much this they clearly had things
under control in their shop code that
things were out of control in that
code and Simon has a it is by no means
true for every sharp project this is
absolutely not true as a universal rule
okay but but Simon likes to tweet on
Friday afternoon I just deployed through
production I'm off to the pub things
like that so so whether he's managed to
maintain this record I'm saying zero
bugs and deployed systems he did say to
me that they had to call up the air the
the balancing services and for whoever
revenue department or whatever to check
that the system was being used because
they were getting no bug reports back
and but he's adamant that our chef is a
safe choice in this particular energy
sector industry right okay
and finally this translates through the
big business results this is the first
ever unicorn on the azure plat are built
using as your first company valued at
over a billion dollars they are nearly a
or an all f-sharp shop gedcom great
stories behind the history of comm and
what the guy who did gedcom did before
he did jet comm he took on Amazon again
this is this is this is you know really
taking on Amazon in the United States
and that's why Walmart acquired them
before this he did diapers.com which was
taking on Amazon in this in the
parenting market that's if you get
people buying buying diapers then you
can get them buying a whole range of
parenting goods an Amazon eventually
bought out diapers comic cuz they were
big enough threat to their market to
that part of the market and then he came
back again and he took them on again him
in in jet and now that's over in
acquired by Walmart and the valuation at
time at the time the acquisition was
over over three billion
right so of course Microsoft is super
happy about that as well from a business
point of view they see high value things
being produced with f-sharp and of
course there are lots of high value
things being produced at c-sharp as well
no doubt about that
but yeah there's we invest in dotnet
partly because it brings revenue to and
bring success for our platforms like
azor for F sharp and C sharp and on it
okay so let's talk about code I love so
I've mentioned this I'm the language
designer I could tell you about the
features of the language
I've got talks about that but people
have been asking me no no we want to
hear what what do you tell us about a
shop coding what is it that you like and
what is it that you don't like so I said
said I could say what I think and I will
do that but there's a fantastic resource
called the F sharp advent calendar
started by F sharp users in Japan I
think way back in 2010 and they did all
the way through 2017 as well I can't
read those because they're in Japanese I
guess I could google translate them but
more recently we've been doing it in
english as well and we get anywhere from
20 to 50 different people to two or
three per day in the December season
leading up to Christmas putting out a
blog post on you know what they love
about that in in F sharp coding putting
out here it's a very focused time way
that you get to summarize what you've
been doing with her sharp during the
year and what are those particular
moments that you really love about F
sharp code and so there's lots and lots
of good resources in that setting
there's some from their shop
Jeff Japan calendar for example okay
right so when we go back in time to when
we started a sharp back in the mid-2000s
here's one of these you know man
isn't that great that's like look at
look at the how around those buttons are
back in 2007 is like really going back
in time for me when I when I could use
this as a modern slide not anymore
that's ancient and awful but anyway this
is how we describe the sharp it said
it's the combination of these things
that we're trying to to get we want to
bring the world of static typing but we
want and you can actually take any two
of these and there's a lot of technical
tension between these things take Java
they get static typing they don't get
succinct nuts
I just heard in the last talk well Java
has got var you know yeah you go for
that so Cygnus you know they're working
it out now you know you know we've you
know we we provoked C sharp to get var
and C sharp provoke Java together the
best way to do technology transfer and
this is technology transfer by NV okay
this is the way you influence the world
as you do something and you make
everyone else envious and gradually
things go go through the system okay of
course we got these constructs that
combine this from Oh camel over there
history of F sharp started with you know
trying to bring that core or the Oh
camel program remodel Internet and they
and they and this problem had been
solved quite a long a long time ago and
and and so good we want that combination
but we did we don't just want that we
want the code dude to scale and that
does mean embracing object-oriented
programming or object programming to
some point we want to have the access to
the full libraries of dotnet we want
exploration and interactive programming
in F sharp eyes scripting and dynamic
evaluation modes of using F sharp we
want to make sure this language is
highly interoperable this was
historically a major problem for
functional languages that they could
hear you could get it you could get some
of these things but you wouldn't get the
interoperability and you look at a
language like Haskell it it struggles
with interoperability in many ways this
is a different VM it doesn't get the
library base it's data types aren't
immediately interchangeable and so on so
we wanted that to to be solved in the
context of f-sharp and of course Scala
took a similar approach for in the
context of the JVM
and we wanted to make sure things were
running efficiently as well okay so
given that you can given up you know
that was the starting point now you can
assume it's fair to say that I love code
that it's a cig I love code that is
expressive in that functional
programming way I love code that
interoperates performant accurate and is
well tooled because that was always what
we've been trying the combination we've
been trying to achieve okay so let's
start with an example so so there's an
example I love that code yeah is a valid
f-sharp program okay this is you know
you don't need anything else no sermon
it's a signal to start with here's an
expression printf with a new line hello
world
that's an f-sharp that's an F sharp
program and yeah that's got the
attributes down here it's a thing that's
expressive but be much more expressive
it interoperates well enough uses the
dotnet libraries underneath the too hard
to do there I oh it's performant as the
low bug wrote and there's well tooled
you hover over print FM and you've got
the documentation for it and that's nice
and good okay that's a good start okay
so I've got to run you through some
things that are very normal in F sharp
code I'm not going to labor them too
much for just to tell you things you'll
see all the time enough sharp blogs and
F sharp coding samples so if you take
pipe lines you'll see this take X some
value X and type it through some
function it's the same thing as taking
the function call it f1 here and
applying it to X okay so you'll see this
all the way through a shop code people
love it people go and suggest that it
should be added to other programming
languages as proposals tab list of
JavaScript Dodds or whatever else people
seem to love it and you can chain these
things together to get a kind of one way
of composing functions you can pipe it
through F 1 F 2 3 and so on okay here's
a typical example just took a random bit
of F sharp code but there is because all
the way through every F sharp
program you take some symbol uses and
you filter it through some function and
then you do a parallel map to use the
multi core capabilities to transform
that to partition it and transform each
partition in a multi-core way then you
take collect up the results if you do a
filter then you do a grouping and then
you do a map over all the different
groups and by Maybank so how'd you go
down okay so I won't labor that anymore
just to say I love that code I love the
the the simplicity the compositionality
of it and I it's it well it's only one I
have to you know drop out of a language
that supports this way of working that I
realized man I really want to be able to
write this code I really like being able
to write it so ok you will see this
consistent thing throughout F hub blogs
and samples that people love using F
sharp for domain modeling domain
modeling both the types in the domain
and the semantics of the domain and
there there there are many different
examples I could choose I tried choosing
one initially because I came from
research you know this is this this is a
sort of stuff that researchers love to
play around with right right it's sort
of representing the past expression for
boolean logic kind of domain maybe
you're dealing with hardware in fact my
job before I worked at Microsoft was
with Intel no no no where we use these
kind of modeling languages to model
combinational logic or register logic to
model what what the floating-point
circuits on a Pentium chip should do and
then we build these really succinct
clear descriptions of what things should
do and then we compare them to the
actual reality of what the chips do and
try and find bugs in implementation so
ok so this might represent the logic of
a are the
the combinatorial logic on a on a on a
chip and so that's fine we have an NAND
or so on and then you just go ahead and
you start writing recursive functions
that do evaluation that do normalization
that compared to a a netlist on an
actual chip in using analysis techniques
so you you visualize these kind of
things okay here's a more domain that I
work in everyday this represents the
optimization information known to the F
sharp compiler so when F sharp is
compiling your code I can actually just
read this off to work out what does the
F sharp compiler know about your code
well it might know nothing about some
expression or might know that some
expression is the same as some other
value that this whatever this value is
it's the same as that x over there this
value F and we know some more things
about it we have the value F what is
equal to every notice more things we
might know that your expression was a
tuple and we might know some element
about each of the things in that tuple
we might know it was a record of a
particular type and we know some more
things about each field we might know
it's a union case which case it is and
what we know about the data its carrying
you might know it's a constant like ah
your code 3 plus 2 that evaluates to 5
so this will be filled in with 5 and we
carry around the type of information
there and we might know our your thing
is actually a function value because we
might want to inline it okay that's for
combining the code so that's all that
the F sharp compiler knows about your
code in the optimization phase that's
our model that's a domain and you read
the rest of optimizer dot FS in the F
sharp compiler and it's all about this
it's about producing these values and
consuming those values in sensible ways
in accurate ways to optimize your code
so for me as a compiler writer that's my
domain that's the model of a domain and
it's as clear as crystal what we do and
don't know and that's what that's what
people love now people use this domain
modeling thing in many other approaches
I'm you know I'm not an expert on domain
on all the applications of the main
modeling but this guy's called Scott
relations some of you might know does
the site f sharp of fun and profit is an
expert
and he's a really good teacher on on
domain modeling I'll talk about its book
in a moment this is the domain model for
error results coming from a covered from
some service for interacting with here
is a domain model of some XML I think
it's like some old data that's coming
back this is done by a guy in Nigeria
called OD and wonderful communicator
about f-sharp and some of these quotes
are worth reading to the choice of data
structures are how you design your
domain it's crucial when writing a code
in F sharp or any language screw it up
and to be walking around in circles
naylet and your implementation will be
concise straightforward and perhaps even
trivial and this if you want to know
more about the main modeling in F sharp
it's really at the core some people it's
at the core of the value proposition for
F sharp there's this slightly out of
focus domain modeling mode functional
that's a book by Scott relation I
strongly recommend to people and also
this book kept programming with F sharp
he's also a great resource that's fresh
out in the last few months and also
highly recommended okay so that's what
else I say so when you look through
those advent calendar blog posts about
half of them are to do with the main
modeling and it's clarity in F sharp and
the clarity of both the types and the
semantics that go along with the types
so this is the place to begin in a sense
to understand why do people love f sharp
what's the value proposition what's the
code that they they love okay I want to
move on to a different area which is
something I'm working on at the moment
which is in this using functional
programming and lot of immutable data
structures to do functional reactive
functional user interfaces and so this
is using this view model update
architecture for thoughtful
for front-end programming and in this
architecture the view function
effectively gets called on every single
update to the model so the model here is
immutable data and that's a really nice
characteristic to have because it means
you can at any point in your in your
your code you can dump out your your
model you can you you can play back in
time through a history of models okay
you can unit test if you've got
functions that take immutable data then
you can unit test these things really
nicely you can say okay given this
particular model representing you know
the underlying knowledge of the of the
UI then and we make a view of it then
then we should get a certain things
appearing on the on the screen for
example or we could take there's a
corresponding update function that takes
messages and processes and them through
the model and gives you new models and
again really easy to unit test and
there's just this business of there's no
mutable state in the coding of the
system it's a really lovely way to
program functional reactive you eyes so
it's based on the Elm architecture this
is called the elvish model for f-sharp
it's supported by fable this all becomes
JavaScript code and you can see here
that these things are great for
dynamically adjusting UI is that if we
have some text in the model or we got no
text in the model it's an empty array
then we say loading a difficult loading
here and if otherwise we we we have a
button here that says go fast service
put the text here and then we say one
thing slower and then we have something
reporting the performance of the system
okay so this is these view functions are
something I'm really falling in love
with as a way of coding you eyes it's
functional reactive dynamic web view
there are various tricks you need to
play to make this stuff efficient
because this view function gets called
on every single update to the model and
there's various ways that are documented
in fable and and other such systems
about how to make sure
you you you pay your paper update you
you you you don't you pay the
performance ends up reasonable this is
the same thing applied to xamarin
programming which is what I'm working at
the moment I'm loving this view model
update architecture so much that I'm
going to apply it to our Android app
Android and iOS app programming so here
we have a view function we're taking
again a model it's a dynamic view
function if the pressed is true in the
this immutable model then we show a
label otherwise to show a button so
people familiar with zamel will see that
we're doing an exam or completely in
code we're not going to write any exam
or files and this means a whole lot of
state disappears from your system in a
really nice way and you can just focus
on code rather than this big mess of
files in an exam all oriented system
this is using the xamarin oriented
version of zamel ok ok so it's a
functional reactive mobile app you in
that case and just to say an entire app
this is entire Android app or iOS you
can run the same thing on iOS using
examine these are this is the full
application ok rather than having tens
of files in your system so let's run
through this we have the the messages
that can be sent from the user interface
from the view we have that the model is
the impressed or not we have the initial
model it's false we have the update
function here how we process messages
how we process the first message and the
new model that we get from that and then
we have this dynamic view function which
is the one we just saw if the model is
pressed we certainly said this and
otherwise we have a button and then we
have some stuff to put it together at
the end ok and nice and sing and I
showed this to a program manager of
Microsoft the other day and he said that
is if something clean it is like as
clean as you can get for how you're
going to write a mobile mobile app
competing with an eight-year-old and
continue with the sunshine triki triki
time to give a talk
yeah I don't write they're gonna skip
this one here and check how we're doing
on time yeah okay okay so this one was
just about scripting and writing tests
with scripts I love that in my day to
day work in F sharp code and this is
about composition one sent in by the
community this is the compile function
for a full compiler and you just see the
phases here going Lex pass by and
optimize cogent and it's the fact that
the language encourages you to work
towards a compositional approach to to
your to your programming
okay f sharp has a feature called type
providers that it's just full of magic
moments where you are where you take
data sources such as CSV or other data
sources and bring them into the language
I'm not going to talk about that in more
detail but I encourage you to take a
look at those okay now we've got to talk
about some code that I don't love okay
and that is there's some functional
programming code I don't like okay I'm
not going to say that all functional
code is good code and I want to talk a
little bit about that I got to give some
examples here are two functions you'll
sometimes see used in some functional
programming things they carry function
and an uncaring function it takes we
don't I don't really care what they do
because I don't like them all right okay
I don't really I don't like it when
people write this kind of nonsense or
you say actually this this is the right
way to do this you to take strings I'll
compare and fake give it to two
arguments you don't do any weird
nonsense or try and do this it's wrong
all right so don't do it okay so I don't
like this you just write this stuff it's
it's indecisive well I just prefer quite
often just write the damn thing out okay
if this thing took two arguments in
sequence like this they'll just just
write it out explicitly okay so there
they're a place so you know it's hard to
catalogue all the ways people can write
in decipherable F sharp code that and
you just don't do it you just look at
your code and analyze it for readability
and traceability and you don't go around
just sort of doing things because
they're cute and so these things
are not in the f-sharp standard library
because I think they lead to bad and
indecipherable code okay this one is in
the F sharp library's the back pipe
operator I talked about the forward pipe
operator which I really really like so
we put in this back five operator as
well and it's really you know there are
some uses of this way you can eliminate
some parentheses by doing this but I
just I just really dislike this code
whoever write this I just don't want to
ever see that kind of F sharp code I do
want to see much more sort of sensible
kind of piping operator cut forward by
an operator code like this so I don't
want to char people to use the back pipe
operator certainly not in beginner code
and you use it a lot less than we do
okay these are these are even worse and
they should never have been in their
shop called library which I've just
never have taken put these in and we
shall kind of get rid of those one way
or the other we'll start deprecating
those or warning those or something will
eventually flush them out of the system
okay so okay now there's this style of
doing functional programming where
you're basically trying to get rid of
any explicit variables and they call
this point three code okay no no
explicit lambdas and no variables at all
were just using lots and lots of
composition it's double operator here
but they're I don't that's not the aim
of you know first-class functions are a
good thing but point three is not
valuable in itself here's some examples
of what people do it let's stop map and
take the plus function and saying a ten
so they say well it's cute we're gonna
add but I haven't even put the argument
in here what Lister we just put the
argument in okay just say we've got some
argument to you and got put the argument
at the end here and saying that like
this code it also point free is not a
good is not a virtue in itself so just
do the obvious thing and say if you want
to add it tend to something then right
at 10 - X is X plus 10 and if you want
to double and increment something then
you do that with a nice name here F
sharp likes nice name
it's code unless I like it there's some
good guidance on this fire guy in their
shop community called Eric's palace he
works for gedcom and they're coding
standards team about there are some
times you want ahead more point free but
on the whole that carries a big burden
of proof before doing this kind of thing
okay so please give explicit arguments
to functions okay you'll see a lot of
fold in it in in our in functional
programming but fold is an interesting
thing where you you take all the
elements right across a data structure
if it's a tree or whatever it is and you
kind of iterate them all and collecting
up some kind of state along the way and
then you get to the end and introducer
result it's the important thing to know
about but it's a blunt it's kind of like
a blunt instrument it's kind of like a
go-to it's not using the structure of
your data there's a great paper by our
guy Steele about sort of fold considered
harmful because you can't paralyze it
it's not using their structure and
knowledge of the data that you're
working with so it's nearly always
better if you want to like add add
something up well do it using these kind
of operators some by max five to choose
an operator try and pick one of the
elements are doing a map and a fold if
you're really going to do a fold or do a
reduce yeah there's you're usually doing
something which carries some kind of
relationship to the data you're working
with and the kind of operation and it's
probably already defined in the F sharp
standard library and you should go and
use one of those so I'll skip that but
sometimes fold here is as hard to
understand as a while loop folds can be
very hard to understand and beware that
they carry a burden of proof you
shouldn't necessarily be using them use
something better okay has this record
type feature which gets used hugely in
those immutable models and it's a really
lovely feature cuz it's so easy to
define here's the initial state of a
program here's some maps or so on okay
so it looks it's people loved record
types but but these things can be
misused okay so record types are good
when the the internal view of a type is
the same as the external view of the
type and these things add up they're the
same thing okay but when they're not
when there's some need to encapsulate
these things or you're adding more to
the interface then then you may be
records are not what you should be using
and so here's an example where actually
it's bad because these rifts actually
represent an old fashioned way of doing
mutable State an f-sharp and so you
actually really want to encapsulate this
mutable State you don't want to leak it
out right across your code so I have
seen some a sharp code it's based on Oh
camel code originally that you let's his
stuff leak out everywhere the problem
with records is this stuff begins to
leak out okay so beware record types
when you need to encapsulate these
things so in this case you would use an
object type you actually want a mutable
of program type here so you make the
thing is explicitly mutable where
necessary and and you would encapsulate
them okay and I'm going to talk about
object-oriented programming now okay so
use record types if things aren't
symmetric okay right so in the last ten
minutes I had tell you about some
opinions on object oriented object
programming it's good and bad okay so
here's what object programming looks
like an F sharp okay these were defining
a class called back to the 2d nice and
succinct nothing functional takes two
inputs and it's constructor
it's what we call an implicit
constructor at the top here these things
become fields in the in the type they we
don't make a field if they're only used
in the construction process this is a
construction process here so yeah but
these ones are actually captured in the
properties here so that becomes another
field here and we have some published
properties here DX and dy if just
properties in the.net sense of
properties have another property here we
have a method down here which produces a
new vector with things scaled nice or
functional
object type showing the function object
ordering to programming can work
perfectly well together so that's good
and that's is running through what I
just said so these are the contracts in
the language we have these constructed
class types or very nice we have these
interface types and a dotnet interface
types and we have expressions here so
you case you have these expression forms
where you create objects or you create
objects that support some interface and
they it's a nice object it's good so
it's nice and simple
okay so here's an example of some early
F sharp code that I made me realize that
shop was heading in the right direction
we have a nice class type and we have
taken some kernels and we make we do
various functional things to create an
Augmented view of this kernels data and
kernel theta and then we publish those
as indexes methods to access that data
structure so that's good a functional
computation of encapsulated tables and
their summaries nice and very common
coding pattern in F sharp okay but yeah
so we gonna support object oriented
programming object programming in some
way then well as I said there's a
slippery slope and so something I did
during the early F sharp design process
and I eventually wrote it up was to
actually deconstruct object-oriented
programming into these lots and lots of
individual features and people have been
encouraging me to do the same with
functional programming as well and I
just want to it so what I've done here
is basically order them from things I
like the things I don't like so much
okay and this and sure enough as you go
down yeah there's a cutoff point around
about here where things aren't
supportively enough charm okay so let's
just group these together I go what do
we do with all of these okay some of
these are there you know some of them
make F sharp a genuinely better language
okay F sharp is a better language
because of the supports object
programming
okay some of them in needed because it's
a dotnet language and some of them just
aren't really needed at all now let's go
through these so these are the things
that I absolutely love and embrace as
part of f-sharp programming dot notation
great instance members implicit
constructors we've seen that we can have
static members index and notation named
arguments optional arguments interface
types and their implementation so this
is all great okay so we embrace those we
look at these ones okay we have some
mutable data it's optional in F sharp we
have this I disposed ienumerable
extension structs delegates and so on a
lot of these are dotnet things okay so
these are things which we use where
necessary but we asks you to kind of use
them tastefully use them respectfully
use them sparingly be sensible about
their use okay these are things which
are getting you know more in the don't
like category okay pervasive nulls we
really don't like those in F sharp
implement implementation inheritance is
really strongly de-emphasize these large
type hierarchy if there's one thing that
F sharp doesn't embrace it's this
hierarchy oriented thinking that sort of
comes from Java and the early
object-oriented days a cat person dog
kind of thinking cats are a cat animal
dog okay so these are going down the
rabbit hole of object-oriented
programming if you find yourself doing
these in F sharp you probably want to
step back and rethink how you're doing
how you're doing these things and
there's some things down here which
aren't supported at all in F sharp we
don't do support to protect the members
because it's so strongly associated with
implementation inheritance and we there
are some things we can't do because
we've met and fairly self types is
something we would do if we if we could
so basically we love these tolerate
these it mostly avoid these there's
nothing technically stopping you doing
some of these things and just forget
about these ones
okay so the way we characterize that in
that shop is to make a distinction
between object programming and object
oriented programming okay so in F sharp
when you're doing object programming and
you're doing it well then you're
focusing on notational convenience folks
are making great api's and this is
something that c-sharp does so well you
know it's like it's object-oriented
programming is really focused on this
API ergonomics that's good we want that
kind of thinking in F sharp go on good
aiming good encapsulation composable
abstractions and we want this thing at
the bottom this we want you to be making
simple things and get out of
encapsulated complex foundations okay if
we compare that with object-oriented
programming okay too often it means
these things objects is the dominant
only way of thinking about things is
everything is an object you must
everything's in the hierarchy you must
think about the hierarchy the whole time
so this overuse of hierarchical
classification and a more cat dog
whatever okay our object oriented
programming leads you to these large
abstractions with lots and lots of holes
and lots and lots of failure points I
focuses on declarations rather than
using expressions and closure something
and there's this thing that
implementation inheritance does which
makes leads you to make complex things
from other complex things by inheriting
complex things and you only can make
things more complex by implementation
inheritance you can't make things
simpler okay and your aim should be to
make something simple out of out of
correct components ok so the F sharp
approach is to embrace object-oriented
programming make it fit but don't
embrace full object orientation unless
maybe you happen to be already in a code
base where you have to use that
technique okay so we find a place to
stop down the slippery down the rabbit
hole
okay I'm going to skip a couple of
sections here I'll just run through
these just mutation I'll skip those
f-sharp has this wonderful construct
called sequence expressions for creating
sequences of data you can use with lists
or arrays as well and there's some
beautiful examples of this kind of thing
really capture the complexity here so
we're creating a list of things we yield
if this is true then yield yield yield
yield yield all the way down then we
recursively yield at the bottom and this
is a beautiful way of writing these kind
of lists and and logic which otherwise
you really need a good notation for
writing this kind of thing it's built on
the same machinery we used to write
async code which was pioneered in F
sharp back in 2006 and became part of
the C sharp and so on here's one example
I particularly like we take some server
client and browser we put them all in
parallel and run them all that's from I
don't know it's something about that I
thought yeah okay that's really know
what that's doing I can see what nice
and declarative yeah and that's the
that's the slightly larger version of
that the definition of the server here
the definition of the client definition
of the browser put them together run
them in parallel and wait for the result
we can do that with sequences Asics seek
here is a similar kind of use of this
general machinery in F sharp for
defining these little languages these
compositional languages there's a Singh
maybe and we're starting to see people
doing really interesting things with web
programming here this is defining the
the logic of a web api and the scope
here where you're defining the
forwarding here and so on through the
API very nice okay to add a few general
comments I love all the software
engineering side of things
debugging commenting testing performance
putting things under CI making sure the
code is readable nothing's meant to
those are foundations in any language
and applied to f-sharp just as much
so please do all the sensible things you
should do in any programming language
but good names with secretary says good
good debugging aids and good comments so
I tried to help encourage you to see
that if shop is full of these delightful
moments so if you really love the code
they get at the end of the day the
features can be used well they can be
used badly so if you're in a shop
programmer please share your experiences
and help to improve the coding standards
and make sure we delight even more
programmers with with this language okay
and that's it thanks very much
[Applause]